[Applause]
[Music]
after the October 2019 elections in
which Mauricio Macri ended his
presidency with a grueling defeat
Alberto Fernandez was sworn in as
president on December the 10th by his
side was Christina Fernandez de Kirchner
as vice president after four years where
it looked like change could be imminent
Argentina went back to square one the
new president now faces two challengers
that seem more complicated to achieve
them winning the paris-dakar rally where
they Ford model-t
number one on the list is try to get the
country out of the tough tough crisis
that it's going through and second is to
consolidate his power under the shadow
of his vice presidents because a new
political war seems to be brooding at
the core of Kirchner ISM
[Music]
and this brings up all sorts of
questions what were fernández's first
measures after he came to power what
steps does the new president plan on
taking to get Argentina out of the ditch
will his plan help what lies ahead the
Gaucho country
[Music]
a tainted legacy yes I know this is
something politicians often promise but
you can't build a house by starting with
the reef a person appeared on GC rock
Adina cantando
Italian caviar on top ice in the Luisa
Giri okay Marco to be worse Elroy if we
want to analyze the toss that Fernandez
has ahead we first need to understand
the country he was handed and the truth
is that the situation that the new
presidents has found himself in isn't
exactly a relaxing tropical cruise not
at all Alberto Fernandez got handed one
of the worst scenarios that a politician
can imagine we've already talked about
it in lots of videos which I'll leave
links for in the description but here
are the three pieces of information to
summarize this apparent race towards the
abyss firstly in 2019 inflation closed
more than 50% his number is equivalent
to more than 10 years of inflation in a
normal country seconds the Argentine
economy is in a recession one of the
greatest economic recessions in the
world by some sectors have dropped by a
whopping ten percent thirds the US
dollar which adds an exchange rate of 42
pesos at the start of 2019 ended the
year at almost 80 pesos in the free
market as you can see a major total and
absolute disaster because the gradualism
of previously democra was so gradual
that some people are still looking for
it the only thing he achieved was a
colossal debt pyramid because in the end
gradualism basically consisted of the
following not cutting public spending
and just making small adjustments in
order to attract more investments that
would make the economy grow with this
strategy the burden of public debt on
the GDP would be reduced over the years
bart of the debt amount itself would not
be reduced at the same time any public
deficits would be bankrolled with more
and more debt
and that's exactly what happened public
spending and debt went down in GDP terms
while the public sector continued to
grow as you can see in this graph year
after year the public deficit just kept
increasing
[Music]
the difference between income and
expenses was basically paid with debt
which created a huge debt balloon that
finally burst forcing Argentina to once
again go running to the International
Monetary Fund basically in the end as
many economic and political analysts
have argued the great difference between
Kirchner ISM and Macker ISM was more a
matter of formal and substance because
their policies were practically the same
it seems that the party doesn't make
much difference
all Argentine politicians seem to share
the same motto more taxes more spending
more controls over and over again
and given the results well the truth is
that knowing exactly what they're
looking for isn't really clear if we
take the resources destined to what is
called social spending we see that from
1983 when democracy returned until 2018
the resources destined for so-called
social expenditure increased by 10% of
the GDP and poverty kept growing or
remained at very high levels you saw it
with Macri social spending reached
record numbers during the same period
that poverty levels shot up according to
the social debt Observatory of the
Catholic University of Argentina poverty
and Argentina reached 40 point 8 percent
and is the highest of the decade these
indices imply that 16 million Argentines
live in poverty and 3.6 million in
extreme poverty to give you a better
idea this country currently has 8
million workers who pay taxes to support
20 million people who directly or
indirectly receive a check from the
state whether at the national provincial
or municipal level obviously this isn't
feasible but let's look at it another
way who in their right minds would
invest a single dollar in a country with
such conditions while this is the
question that the new government is
gonna have to face but maybe you think
I'm exaggerating well check the analysis
that the tax payers Association prepared
in Argentina more than half of the price
of a car consists of taxes
specifically on average 54.8% of the
price of a new car consists of taxes yep
more than 50% and this is just for cars
that a half manufactured and sold within
Argentina because if we talk about
imported and high-end cars the taxes
would rise even more as well as the
price this is why in Argentina a
high-end car can cost up to three times
more than it would in the United States
and more than twice what it costs in the
European Union countries where car sales
also have significant taxes
[Music]
and that helps to explain why buying a
late-model car in Argentina like the
ones found in any country in the
developed world isn't an option for
everyone
but that's not all we can also
illustrate the points by looking at a
typical shopping cart according to the
Argentine Institute of fiscal analysis
more than 40% of the price of the usual
food and not alcoholic beverages that
people buy consists of taxes
[Music]
at this point the burning questions are
faced with such a scenario what measures
has Fernandez taken and what strategy
has he chosen
[Music]
the new governments pass
given the situation with Argentina
drowning in the third highest inflation
rate in the world with an economy that's
in freefall into huge national debt what
measures has Fernanda taken as he
decided to end the deficit once and for
all has he decided to approve new
incentives so foreign companies will
invest in the country well not exactly
the new government has approved a very
harsh adjustment perhaps more severe
than expected the problem is that the
adjustment once again doesn't include
the public sector while the private
sector is going to take a considerable
blow no one will touch the public sector
no cuts to administrative expenses or
political expenses or bureaucratic
expenses so what does this adjustment
really consist of well let's take a look
at the main measures
[Music]
[Applause]
first of all they're raising taxes again
rates are raised withholding taxes on
agricultural exports are increased this
is a kind of export tax for a very
important sector in Argentina and most
importantly the non-taxable amounts on
personal taxes will be updated the
latter considering that the country has
an inflation rate of more than 50% is
something that amounts to a huge fiscal
bite for taxpayers with a lower income
[Music]
but let me explain this a bit better you
see in every country taxes especially
personal taxes tend to have exemptions
so if you earn less than a certain
amount you don't have to pay
well in Argentina not updating this
minimum considering the increases in
inflation will come as a tough blow to
many people imagine for example that a
freelancer a professional has an
exemption threshold of a million pesos
so everything he or she earns above that
is taxed
[Music]
as inflation sits at more than 50%
imagine that this professionals income
last year increased by 30 percent to 1.3
million pesos the professional is
actually poorer than the previous year
because his or her income has increased
less than the rate of inflation so they
won't be able to buy as much with the
greater amount of money
[Music]
however on top of this taxes need to be
paid on the 300,000 pesos as they exceed
the exemption threshold which means the
take-home pay is even lower and buying
power is weakened even more well that's
exactly what's gonna happen in Argentina
higher tax rates and an updated minimum
tax threshold mean more fiscal pressure
it doesn't end there another group that
it's really going to feel the adjustment
is retirees given the high inflation
rates the Macri government established a
kind of semi-annual adjustment so that
pensioners wouldn't lose so much
purchasing power while the new
president's has decided to freeze that
update for a hundred and eighty days for
all retirees who earn more than two
hundred and fifty dollars per month and
of course given the enormous inflation
that exists in the country this will
mean a very significant loss in
purchasing power in other words a harsh
blow to the wallets of retirees that's
not the end of it personal property tax
which is something like a wealth tax has
also been raised and hold on because in
Argentina the law considers everyone who
has assets worth more than thirty
thousand dollars to be rich it's pretty
crazy
perhaps out of all the recent measures
the most controversial one is the new
policy regarding the dollar Fernandez's
government has imposed a 30 percent
surcharge for all people who want to
save in dollars or who simply want to
buy products or services abroad this is
known as the solidarity dollar
that way even though the official
exchange rate is about 60 pesos per
dollar if you want to buy dollars to
travel abroad or to import a camera the
exchange rate applied to the transaction
will be over 80 pesos per dollar if you
want to travel invest or buy things
abroad then you have to pay for the
privilege that's just the way things are
as if this weren't enough the amount of
dollars that you can buy is officially
capped at $200 per person so if you want
more than that you'll have to exchange
your money on the streets in the black
market let's take a moment to think
about all this even though in principle
companies aren't affected imagine a
small Argentine professional who exports
products worth $10,000 when this money
enters the country they will exchange it
at the official exchange rate which is
six hundred thousand pesos now let's
assume that that same professional wants
to use that money to buy some equipment
in say Germany which costs ten thousand
dollars
well then it's a bit of a problem
doesn't it when he goes to exchange his
money back two dollars he'll get the
solidarity dollar exchange rate which is
30% more expensive so his 600 thousand
pesos will only get in 7,500 dollars and
not only that if he wants to go ahead
with that transaction his company will
have to go to the black market because
he won't be able to buy more than the
200 dollars
so here's the question do you think that
this is the best way to attract
investment and grow businesses well it
really doesn't seem to bode well it's
true that with these adjustments the
government is sending a clear message
the international markets that Argentina
wants to pay will pay its debts and
therefore will be able to renew its
credits and even obtain more
international financing but the problem
is that if it doesn't touch public
spending and only punishes the private
economy even more Argentina runs the
risk of drowning completely
[Music]
this is not an easy situation that's
clear but hey maybe politicians could
start the adjustment by setting an
example right
check out the calculation that Roberto
catch an OS key developed based on the
2019 budgets take a look
[Music]
anyway that's how things stand in
Argentina Alberto fernández's government
has begun his mandate with some harsh
adjustments adjustments that follow the
Argentinian tradition could it be that
Argentine politicians don't know any
better
in visual politic we'll be keeping an
eye on how events unfold so I really
hope you enjoyed this video please do
hit that like button if you did and
don't forget to subscribe for brand new
videos also please do check out our
friends at the reconsider media podcast
they provided the vocals in this episode
that were not mine also this channel is
possible because of patreon and our
patrons on that platform please consider
joining them and supporting our mission
of providing independent political
coverage and as always I'll see you in
the next video and if you want to learn
more about politics and hear even more
of my lovely voice you can join us at
reconsider media we have a podcast at
reconsider mediacom slash podcast see
you there